So now that we have seen how paging and
V->P translation works,
let's talk about the memory access
time when we have this translation.
So our program does something like this.
It says load R1 from the address
computed by adding 4 to what is in R2.
This, when computed,
will be the virtual address that
we want to access in the program.
So to do a load/store, the processor
has to compute the virtual address.
This is quick.
Usually, it's just addition of
two numbers that are already in
the processor.
One is a constant fetch
with instruction.
The other one is the register
that is inside the processor.
Next, the presser has to compute the
page number, which is extremely quick
because it just means that we take
some bits from the virtual address.
And without any address translation, the
next thing that the processor will do is
access the cache, and sometimes if there
is a cache miss, the actual memory.
So again, these two are extremely quick.
Most of the time will be spent
accessing the cache, and occasionally,
we will spend more cycles because
we need to access the memory.
With V->P Translation,
after computing the page number, the
processor has to compute the physical
address of the page table entry where
the translation for the page number is.
This is done by adding the page
number that we computed
to the beginning address
of the page table.
Then we read the actual
page table entry, and
compute the physical address by
combining the physical frame number
from the page table entry with the page
offset from the virtual address.
So how fast is this?
Well, this is fast,
because it just means adding the page
number to some sort of address.
This is fast,
because it only means combining
two numbers that you already have.
But how fast is this?
And for that, we need to ask ourselves,
so where is the page table?
Is it inside the processor so it can be
quickly accessed, or is it in memory?
We have seen the page
table can be fairly large.
Yes, for a multilevel page table we can
have it be less than a megabyte for
some programs, but
in theory it can be extremely large.
So, we cannot guarantee that the page
table for even one process fits on
the processor chip, which means that the
page tables really need to be in memory.
And that means, that for
each load or store,
we now need to have a memory access,
which is just as slow as when we have
a cache miss that we were trying to
avoid before we got to page tables.
Things are even worse, because for
a multi-level page table, for example,
a 4-level page table,
we would need to do this multiple times.
For example, 4x.
Compute the physical address of the
outermost page table, read that entry,
compute the physical address of
the next page table, go ahead and
do that four times.
So we need four memory accesses to read
the four page table entries until we
get the actual translation, after
which we can quickly access the cache.
So somehow,
we have a situation where the virtual to
physical address
translation is costing us
more than the memory access is that
we try to avoid by having the caches.